hello everybody my name is nya and i'm
the black female engineer i provide
content for new and aspiring software
engineers and
i am so excited to be doing this video
because i've been
in quite the limbo um of not knowing
what
is going to be happening for the next
few months and now i have a good amount
of answers that i would love to just
share with you all so yeah let's just
get right into it so
first things first some of you may
already know especially if you follow me
on instagram at the black female
engineer
but i am moving
i am moving and i am so
excited because i just really wanted a
fresh start i've been
living in the midwest for the last like
12 years i spent my
childhood in queens so i've been living
here for like 12 years now
and i went to college nearby and so i'm
just ready to
just just
go somewhere and have a good you know
experience and everything so where am i
moving to
i am moving to los angeles
oh my gosh i've been wanting to move to
los angeles since before
college is actually where i wanted to go
for college
one because of the weather i am not a
fan of the cold like no you can keep
that
so i'm just so excited to have some sun
i'm a person who
can very easily be affected by the
weather and so just
have some sun have some beach have some
mountains as well have like really just
anything my heart desires and if i want
some snow i'll just
take a plane back and like go to like i
don't know vail or something
so i am so so happy to be moving i found
this out
like four days ago about four days ago i
found this out
i knew i would be moving for my new job
i started a new job
in august and so i knew i would be
moving
but i didn't know where so i got hired
by a big
company and they have so many different
teams so many many companies so many
subsidiaries
that i had no idea where they would put
me what team i'd be
on the location i had no clue i worked
for a fortune 50 company and so
it's that's pretty common with companies
that size
but yeah i had no idea where i'd be and
so i was just kind of sitting here
twirling my thumbs just
kind of waiting for the phone to ring
until yeah four days ago they let me
know i'd be
in los angeles working in animation
and so super excited but also i'm
a nervous because i'm like okay
gonna be learning some new languages
it's okay i
got it it's fine especially because i
just now um
went through that process of going into
a job that i didn't know the language
and learning and trying to figure things
out so quickly because
you're learning but you're also trying
to help and you know
be a part of the team and be a resource
to everybody
but how can i when i don't know what
we're using
so that's giving me some anxiety
um to think about being in that
situation again of
being the person who doesn't know for a
little bit but i'm also very excited to
learn oh my gosh so excited to learn
never thought i would
be on like when i thought about all the
teams i could be on with them
to be honest animation never really came
to mind
we just showed up it definitely should
have i just didn't it just didn't come
to mind i thought
it'd be more on working with their apps
and things like that
but no i'm so pumped but i also don't
have many details
right now in the next like four weeks
so many things will be answered for me
and so i'll provide another
update later on on the languages
i specifically will need to learn as
in the role i'm in and the day-to-day
and things like that
and i'll also share more as you know as
i start working in august and give you
more
play-by-plays so i'm going to be
apartment hunting next month because
i already had planned a trip down there
just you know it's summer and i
wanted a beach and so i decided to just
extend the trip and do some apartment
hunting as well that way
i'm not just like flying back and forth
throughout the summer and so yeah let me
know if you'd like me to do some
apartment hunt videos yeah that's
work and then on the another side of
work as well for the summer i actually
won't
be working my most recent job in
commerce cloud development
i finished also
like a minute ago when just a couple
days ago
finished that as well but i'm sure by
the time you also see this
some time may have passed as well but
yeah finished it not too long ago i
decided to just let that be not try to
get another contract for the summer or
anything so i had to just
chill for a little bit i haven't had a
summer break
in like oh like six years throughout
college i always worked in the summer
and then
i started working when i was 16 and
worked throughout the summer so this is
something i haven't
had in a very long time and so i was
like you know what better time than
before i start my first grown-up job and
so i'm so excited
to just get to focus on me focus on
projects focus on y'all
and just chill take a break for this
summer before i start this new stage
in my life along with being anxious
about the languages i'll need to start
learning
i'm also kind of anxious about being in
la
in general i mean vacationing somewhere
is
quite different i imagine than living
somewhere
and so if any of y'all live in los
angeles please like dm me at the black
female engineer
or put in the comments just some tips or
you know some advice or insights you
have to offer because
i this is just i i do have anxiety i do
have a problem
sometimes with maintaining my anxiety
and so i'm trying
very hard to not just unravel
up in here and everything because i am
nervous about
one being there by myself and of course
there's different stereotypical
themes people talk about with los
angeles and being a person in los
angeles
and you know things like that and so
those are typically are really the
things that are kind of
making me all flustered like i am right
now so i
am just going to work on this breathing
and just
staying excited and just going and just
doing it
i use i'm a quotes person i love quotes
and so i saw this quote that was like
do it scared and so that's this one i'm
going to do i'm just going to do it
scared what's great is this is something
i've been talking a lot about
with my therapist if you watched my day
in the life videos
and one of them i talked about going to
therapy as i'm very open about it i
think it's important to be
um given especially given the climate
we're in
and so it's something i've been going
talking with my therapist a lot talking
about my anxieties
and so the idea of being in
la where a lot of people are
content creators um or
in show biz or you know even now i'm
working
in quan co entertainment that also gets
me you know a little
a little flustered and so i'm going to
be working on that in therapy over the
next few
weeks and probably for the next you know
a couple years to be completely honest
with you
if you'd like me to do a video kind of
like a black girl's guide to
therapy in my transition to therapy and
really just a more detailed
look into all of that how i found them
and all of that please let me know i
kind of tried to keep this channel as
focused to what i think you all are here
for
so if you ever want something different
or something new please let me know
because i'm kind of just
like working on what i hear and see
around me so let please let me know a
lot of what i've been doing lately is
trying to figure out how to progress
this channel
what to talk about what things i should
maybe stop talking about
what different avenues of things i can
explore in terms of like
diversification and so one of the things
i
was hoping to do if you all want it is
apartment hunts and moving in
and like moving vlogs and day in the
lives of
with orientation week and first week and
first month and things like that
and just share more instead of focusing
most of my time on instructional videos
still doing those because i do still
like doing those but
also putting in a slot for more sharing
like this
and so let me know what ideas you guys
have um
because yeah right now it's focused on
is going to be focused on my transition
into this yeah now big girl big company
big city job yeah i just wanted to take
a second to just update you all
i do mini updates on instagram but i
feel like this was too
much for me to just put in you know a
story or something
and too temporary and so i wanted to
just provide you all with this
and just share and thank you so much to
anyone
all of you who have reached out and
shown your support from me
been kind to me i really appreciate that
you have no idea how much i appreciate
your kindness
to me um and so i really thank you for
that and i'm so excited for these next
few months where i get to just
share more with you all especially share
more as they
um as things come rather than like with
boot camp where it's like oh this is
what i did x amount of months ago or x
amount of
years ago or whatever but being able to
kind of do things more in real time so
i'm so excited
to just let that all happen in the next
few months
but no thanks for watching this let me
know yeah what advice you have for me in
these next few months with the move with
the transition with the new job
and yeah just you know you know where to
find me
so i know thank you so much for watching
and i'll see you all later bye